il n'y a pas besoin je suis au bam 2 sa
maison familiales situées aux abords de
raquives il ne reste plus qu'un amas de
tôle et de débris
jeter un œil mais on ne peut pas se
rendre à l'intérieur c'est humide et le
plafond posséder mais Yuri n'a pas pour
autant renoncé à sa vie ici il compte
désormais tout reconstruire aux côtés de
ses proches
miraculeusement épargné par les frappes
russes qui se sont abattus sur leur
village
nous n'avons plus qu'une seule solution
tout retirer d'ici car rien ne peut
vraiment être réparé nous allons tout
démonter puis reconstruire lentement à
perdre vos maïs comme dans les autres
localités autour de raquives l'entraide
s'organise la municipalité a même
débloqué des fonds pour les sinistrés
les trois familles qui ont subi le plus
de dégâts ont reçu chacune près de 1300
euros piocher dans le budget local la
troisième environ 900 euros
regard des besoins dans des lieux par
plusieurs mois de bombardements
incessants et pervomaïques est à l'image
d'autres villages ukrainien défiguré
comme shiroki situé lui près de
nicolaïves au sud 95% des
infrastructures ont été détruites ici
sur les 800 habitants que comptait
cherokeeves seules
notre village et celui d'à côté était
sous un déluge de feu quotidiens nous
n'avions pas un seul jour de répit à
certains moments j'ai compté une
centaine de frappes sur notre seule
village
au niveau national le coût de la
reconstruction pourrait s'élever à 350
milliards d'euros au bas mot